the only thing they can be short of
about the future is it will be
absolutely fantastic it is my pleasure
to be joined with a friend of mine Greg
Zuckerman
it's an author and writer this was not
picking up on there's a book coming in
here this is the man who can't solve the
market how Jim Simons launched the
Quandt revolution and I'm Bryan Keating
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination UC san
diego's arthur c clarke center for human
imagination and this is the into the
impossible podcast
based on one of Arthur C Clark's laws he
had many laws one of which you're
probably familiar with that any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
you probably heard that before and then
the another one is the only way to find
out what's possible is to go a little
bit beyond into the impossible and so
that's what we like to think of
ourselves here we talk of creative
people with folks all over the world in
all different genres from studies of the
cosmos near and dear to my heart to
business leaders thought leaders such as
yourself Julian Guthrie you're gonna
have Peter Diamandis on soon science
fiction writers like Anna Leigh Nuits
and David Brin and and then sometimes we
do things are just of interest to me
like Krav Maga the physics of Krav we
did an episode on that so I want to
bring to people's attention
that's this book which is phenomenal
book and not just because you took an
epigraph I was gonna say epitaph but
graph chapter six but you've also
written many other books and actually I
came to know you this isn't showing up
super well but we'll put a link to it
there there's this is one of your other
books written with your two sons called
rising above this one's about inspiring
women in sports and you have another one
inspiring men in sports and this or
these are wonderful books because
they're really written for middle grade
type audiences and many of us have
middle graders at home and we're running
an unlicensed middle grade school as we
speak
and so yeah those books tie-in biography
and sports and I think life lessons in a
way that are sort of unique and I find
the somatic of your work so thank you
Greg for joining us and it's great to be
here and I'm a big fan of your own book
so whoever has purchased a copy I
recommend it
just as an observer not a science person
myself but it was it was eye-opening and
educational and also enjoyable yeah so I
actually got a an email from you and you
were writing when I was writing my book
and you were you know asking some some
interesting questions about the project
that I'm involved with called the Symons
Observatory hopefully we'll get to that
but I wanted to first take the
opportunity you may not know if you
haven't listened to some of our podcast
guests with authors I never like to give
away the you know the topic of the book
too much in too much detail the thesis
of the book in some cases however your
book because I don't want to compromise
sales you know book sales because you
know many authors rely on book sales but
I think in your case because your book
was essentially number one and still is
in the shop
you know 10 or so on Amazon another fine
booksellers I think we will get into a
little bit more of the nuts and bolts of
your book but first of all
congratulations on that it's really not
not just in your category many of us
have been number one and some of us have
been number one always delighted to be
that way but for you to be number one in
all of Amazon is just such a phenomenal
accomplishment and no surprise because
your books are quite quite amazing to
read for the record I think only hits
three on Amazon so just for the right
okay all right well that's mrs. Nichol
erm when it comes to accuracy but yeah
that's right okay and you've had other
books of course in the business world of
course this book written not too long
ago this was also a best-seller this is
called the frakkers and this was the
kind of just unbelievable story of how
the United States really got to this
preeminence and sort of wildcatting and
the exploration of natural resources oil
gas etc and I should also mention for
the audience who's not familiar with
Greg that he is also a special writer
for The Wall Street Journal and you've
been there how long
Greig decades right I've been there
since 1996 actually coming up on 24
years yeah so it's a long time to be at
any one organization institutions so
yeah they treat me well I like them so I
stayed yeah it's a great publication we
are subscribers and we we always enjoy
your writing and your compatriots over
there so I want to talk about Jim
Simon's because he is he's sort of this
in one sense very inscrutable character
who has had at least three careers and
three careers that he sort of is
commonly associated with first being
math professor mathematician back in the
60s 70s and even the beginning of the
80s the second one is as a hedge fund
Titan running one of the most if not the
most successful in terms of return on
investment hedge funds in history
through his Renaissance Technologies
hedge fund and then the third career is
sort of what he's obsessed with for the
last couple of decades along with his
wife Marilyn Symons is running a large
philanthropy which is one of the largest
if not the largest philanthropies that
supports what we call pure scientific
research this is research without the
direct aim of coming up with with a drug
or you know some new design for
something it's actually pure and apply a
pure research so mathematics computer
science you know quantum quantum
chemistry quantum materials things like
that and of course cosmology
astrophysics that I study and he's I
really think he's almost started a
fourth career and tell me if you agree
Greg with the Flatiron Institute it's
sort of he's now like a college
University founder I mean it's a thing
Hank but it's but it's a huge enterprise
so let me start with that do you find
the last of these four careers you know
is is that sort of out of place or is
that in keeping with his visionary
status in in the preceding three
different fields isn't just another
challenge that falls along cleaves along
the same lines well first I have to
correct you he actually had an earlier
career that wasn't law wasn't many years
but he it was a distinct career and that
he was a code breaker during the Cold
War
freaking code Allah you know Alan
Turing's and similarities against the
Russians and that was another
interesting fascinating career where as
for this one there are some similarities
you could and it is a remarkable last
leg of his life in that he is tackling
all kinds of big questions and in some
ways make challenges and I think that's
what he enjoys and behind it all is it's
what he's gone after what he enjoys
doing math early on people discouraged
him his family doctor kind of said oh
you can't make any money career focusing
on math and today's worth twenty three
billion dollars and major funder of
political candidates and such so he was
wrong there that the family doctor but
in each of these care legs in his career
it's something he's passionate about but
also he likes taking on challenges and
today it's everything is as you know
trying to and I love kind of airier
thoughts in terms of the origins of life
which I find personally kind of
fascinating and that's it's another
question that people struggled with for
years for just light and it's not so
different from solving the market I mean
for thousands of years people been
trying to understand how to best
competitors and figure out solutions and
outsmart rivals when it comes to beating
the market and Jim kind of has and but
that was a similar kind of question and
these are lifelong questions others have
struggled with and he takes on and yeah
that's the Flatiron Institute some
extent to you can make some similarities
with Flatiron terms of embracing data
and being a scientist he's always been a
scientist and looking for patterns and
looking when others kind of see chaos he
who kind of looks for order and I think
that's what a scientist is trained to do
to some extent so there are a lot of
similarities when it comes to all these
legs and Jim Simon's career yeah yeah
and I think you know one thing that
really categorizes him as he's extremely
curious I think the thing that he is
most you know related to in my mind is
his you know
relentless curiosity and he calls it
pondering he calls it you know sort of
this deep thought that he has but it's
what's so amazing to me to see him and
Marilyn both they you know they can talk
very deeply about aspects of
experimental cosmology detector
development you know Dark Matter dark
energy and then you know he can go pivot
immediately in so can Marilyn into you
know de novo genetic you know
modifications phenotypes epigenetic
effects in autism to other other effects
and that differences between sexes in
the animal kingdom it's just phenomenal
how how both you know broad and deep
they they both are and I think now I'm
really caught she's really I think his
secret weapon because you know she's you
know several years his junior incredibly
passionate herself and incredibly
energetic and she she just has this
relentless spirit to pursue knowledge
even you know it catch her when she's I
think she's having a down time you know
or just you know just doing you know
kind of decompressing and she's doing a
crossword puzzle and pen you know this
is it's really phenomenal to see how the
two of them complement each other and he
hey talents as far as I know he's he
really doesn't like doing you know he's
solving these puzzles and games and
stuff like that one thing that's
interesting about Jim is that he's sort
of an outsider I mean yes he did work
for the I da and and now we kind of
associate you know the NSA as being if
not the biggest probably one of the
biggest employers and mathematicians in
the whole planet and so you know they're
obviously involved in code breaking and
forecasting etc I want to talk first
about you know the renaissance
technologies so when it started I wonder
did people sort of you know laugh at
that name or maybe you can talk about
the etymology of the name I know it but
but could you say if you explain to the
readers what you know how does that come
about why is it Renaissance technologies
and in what sense is it a technology I
mean come on it's just you know computer
trading right so what's that's Ryan
really a technology sure why don't I
kind of take a step back the lot of your
audience doesn't realize this guy Jim
Simon's mathematician acclaimed
mathematician
most important geometers in the past
fifteen hundred years has impact in
worlds mathematics but also physics she
is the greatest money maker in the
history of modern finance and I used
that term specifically if that clear is
he a traitor is he invest there he's not
investor the way we traditionally define
those kinds of people but yet his firm
to this day is the most respected on
Wall Street so I'm sure many of your
audience know him from the world of
science and mathematics but when it
comes to trading and investing and
making money on Wall Street there's no
one like him and he in some ways as a
pioneer when it comes to developing
mathematical models to trade this
quantitative approach computers as
opposed to intuition and judgment and
gank your question so basically he gave
up academia gave up mathematics to some
extent in 1978 and said you know what
I'm gonna try my hand at trading and
investing it it kind of goes to your
point as being an outsider when you talk
to Jim and I've been lucky enough to
spend time with them and I've seen every
interview and such um he sort of sees
himself as an outsider in that even when
he was in the world of mathematics he
sort of had one foot in that world and
he had the other four world firmly
placed in the real world as it were he
was trading he was investing too he
liked the market he couldn't always
didn't always have the time to focus on
them but he's very unique in that regard
he's also just an outsider and his
personality and you know better than I
do but um many mathematicians I don't
want to generalize or stereotype but
they're not the most outgoing sorts
usually or often you know the joke about
mathematics mathematicians is an
outgoing one is one who stares at your
shoes as opposed to his or her own shoes
during a conversation and again it's a
stereotype it's not always the case I
met many many and the course of my
research for the book but ah you can
generalize to some extent often and
Jim's not like that he is a guy you
wanna have a beer with he is funny
mischievous smokes like a chimney I
likes to drink as
interesting guy as you suggested earlier
he's curious about the world around him
about others not focus on himself always
so he took an outsider's approach and
for a while though in other words he
decided to embrace mathematical models
and it did work for a while it went back
and forth and ganked the name it has
technologies sort of suggests maybe a
venture capital kind of firm and that's
because it was they were doing other
kinds of things and for a while we're
talking years it wasn't clear if he was
gonna make it when it came to investing
and trading and maybe he had more
success as a venture capitalist so it
took until really I argue 1990 from 1978
to 1990 they kind of turned the corner
but as late as sort of 1988 1989 he was
a hundred percent focused on trading and
he was doing sort of venture capital
kind of an investing kind of activity
which is suggested by the name yeah yeah
and I think you know what's what's
interesting with Jim is that he is very
self analytic he understands what makes
him tick I think better than anybody and
it's not so much that he does you know
kind of have that chess playing poker
playing I think was his game mentality
where he is sort of attuned as you as he
said you know he is he has a secret edge
which i think is that his personality is
one that's very sensitive so we are
supported our research is supported on
the Simons Observatory obviously by the
Simons Foundation and you know just as
an example of his leadership and as well
as maryland's you know within a few days
after the co bid crisis really struck
you know he got correspondents from the
top down that you know they're they're
here to support us you know mentally
physically and we have 300 people
working on every continent including
Antarctica as you know for this project
and just that he's so you know deeply
concerned with not not how fast can we
get back going and you know beat the
competition or whatever but but really
just about us as human beings yeah I
think he's always really noted that I
think he tailored his approach you know
I asked him once you know how did you
deal with these squabbles
amongst faculty so he was the first
chairman of the faculty in mathematics
at the formerly known the State
University of New York at Stony Brook I
believe now it's called Stony Brook
University where he Co taught and
actually recruited my my late father
James axe to come from Cornell to work
with him who was in was a major
character in my book may I ask sir Jeff
yeah yes he is and I'm thankful that is
his legacy you know comes through in the
book but when we talk about the you know
kind of personalities it takes to really
deal with faculty there's an old joke
amongst amongst you know the academic
set that well you know the reason that
academic squabbles and the Faculty Club
are so intense is because the stakes are
so low if there's anyone who deals with
high stakes it's Jim or at you know has
been typically throughout his career it
was Jim but in the case of you know
faculty you know I don't sense it like
how did you what was your leadership
philosophy told me something very
interesting he said you know a lot of
faculty and I think this applies to
corporations as well faculty will get
really wound up about stuff and it could
be that there's some legitimacy to that
that they actually have you know a good
reason to be you know kind of enthused
and passionate and squabbling about
things but it could be that you're just
spinning their wheels and he said you
know I would have to you know quickly a
prize situation was it you know in
category a or category B and if it was
in some aspect that I cared about well
then I get involved but most of the time
I wasn't as involved I let them hash it
out
so he'd let them have these brutal you
know back-and-forth battles you know for
hours and and then he would you know
leave be very hands-off and then when it
was time for him to act when there was
something important to him then he would
say and then he had accrued a lot of
poker chips that he could go all-in on
and I think it afforded him a lot of
credibility with other faculty that he
would both listen to them and then he
would only speak when something was
truly important so people knew when he
was speaking that that Jim had you know
deeply thought about the problem and
that was very meaningful for him but he
also allowed other people intentionally
to work on things for themselves and
hash things out for themselves I think
that's a leadership style but you know I
tried to emulate as much as I can
the other thing you know that I took
from him I mean famously they're very
secretive at Renaissance I have no idea
how things work over there never did I
only knew that they had this huge
advance stockpile of data actually
dating back as you point out in the book
you know perhaps hundreds of year you
know shipping manifests you know back to
the back to the you know 1700s or
something and in the Malacca Straits of
even Malaysia or whatever and that you
know and they had these signals as all
hedge funds to that summer long term
summer short term but I think it's
ironic that for a firm that's so
predicated on data analysis and data
crunching that it's really not the
machine learning ask there's more the
psychology that he he came to be so
adept at and through his well you know
well schooled education and human
dynamics in psychology he has this
ability to you know calm people whether
it be investors as you talked about in
the book during crises and even his own
employees when they have these
internecine squabbles so the book shines
I think brightest of course I you know I
like most of the stuff and I like the
stuff about me and I'm not going to be
I'm not going to deny that but
leadership books it's actually as I call
it a stealth leadership I've given it to
a bunch of friends cosmologists why
would it cosmologist care about this I
think it's a stealth leadership books
okay was that your intention
no and it's facet you say that because
it didn't occur to me until I was done
with a book that it is as much a
management book as it is a trading book
and it's funny you go on Amazon and I'm
sure you know the UM the feeling and you
only focus on the bad reviews that the
great ones you know don't really care
about I'll let you know when I get one
I'll let you know
a good mine and most of mine bad ones
are well yeah it's a good story Greg but
I want to learn how to be a billionaire
myself there's no formulas in here where
the formulas that I can embrace and the
senior people executives Wall Street
types but others too who really enjoy
the book I think most of them pick up on
that that same theme that they've
learned some management skills because
that's what makes them so unique I go
around the country and I give speech
I used to until Covina and and people
are always kind of say what's the secret
sauce what's the secret sauce or
Renaissance and they've got the greatest
date and they got computer and they got
the talent etc but I think the secret
sauce is how Jim has managed that talent
how he's recruited it and he goes back
to Stony Brook and the there are skills
there there are all kinds of techniques
and tactics in which he's recruited he
recruited your father in a very unique
way he got your father who was the
youngest or one of the youngest tenured
professors ever at Cornell to leave
Cornell for this turn upstart overlooked
department at Stony Brook with uh with
Jim leading it was really no reason for
him to have gone and he had ways he was
able to persuade people to leave their
jobs and he applied some those
techniques at Renaissance and I think we
could all kind of learn them too but
that is his ability to he understands
the quantitative approach he is a
mathematician he can build algorithms he
enjoyed doing that both when he was a
codebreaker and later as well but the
key thing for it for him is he can talk
he can get people to work together and
maybe it's like that in the world of
academia maybe it doesn't always but
that's been his approach that unlike
every other firm and I've been working
on Wall Street again writing my walls
for 23 years no one has an approach like
Renaissance where people hundreds of
people or at least for short dozens of
people work together at the firm every
other firm that's about silos you make
some discovery you keep it for yourself
you don't share it with others and dream
all about people working together so all
kinds of fascinating themes that I
learned about management management
techniques and way to get super smart
talented quirky often stubborn
frequently individuals to work together
yeah and exactly so I you know again you
wouldn't think that a business tycoon
would have lessons to teach a practicing
cosmologists but you know here's another
example so Jim told me once that there
radically transparent within within
Renaissance technology radically you
know kind of opaque outside is crazy
they are yeah
and it's kind of the opposite of even
like Bridgewater Ray Dalio is another
famous even maybe richer you know hedge
fund Titan in his book principles are
wonderful
he talks about how they would videotape
every single meeting and if it didn't
have something confidential or
proprietary related to a trade they
would actually make it public so Jim
didn't go quite that far but he gave me
a wonderful tip that I've used for the
last 10 years and that was that all
their meetings they have a weekly
meeting or where they'd all go around
and just talk about what they were
working on their trade ideas their
signal analysis ideas these are quasi
like you said they're not typically you
know very very much you know comfortable
getting out of their shells but everyone
goes around and it's similar with
quantitative cosmologists right so they
don't want to do that anymore but it
brings them out and the thing that we do
in my group meeting every Friday is all
my students go around the room there's
30 of us and undergraduates grad
students postdocs other faculty and we
all say what do we do this week what
challenges do we face because it could
be at all I'mI'm in Python and I have
this overflow you know this problem or
that problem or and then I had that last
year you have to install this library
good and you know it's something that I
wouldn't have done so recouped
productivity you know time hours
multiplied by the IQ points of these
people and I think it's a lot and and
and of course I think you know that that
lesson came from Jim one thing that's
kind of you know a little more
enervating about Jim is that he and
maybe it's just his honesty but he talks
frequently you know very surprisingly
for someone who's so quantitative who's
so data-driven he talks about the role
of luck and how big a role it played in
his life and I wonder if you could
comment you know does this does it seem
as in Congress to you that this you know
quantitate literate quant you know it's
the S&C the epitome of a reliability
forecasting signal yeah then he says
almost the wife is not well he's had a
lot of bad luck you know I think he has
has had to come to grips with that
aspect I'm referring that his personal
life
yes he's worth twenty three billion
dollars and has a gorgeous yacht which
I'm sure you've been on thing I would
never has a journalist I couldn't go on
it but super yachts where hundred
million dollars and as a happy marriage
thankfully but he's also lost two
children at young
ages to fluke accidents but one in which
a son was riding a bicycle and an
elderly woman backed up and crushed him
within seconds and the other and a
diving accident so I think he's had to
confront the issue of luck be a good
luck or bad luck in his life and he
frequently talks to people about how
he's had the the hi seen the highs and
lows of life and yes they know they've
got a really good sense of when they can
make money and they crunch they turn out
some of the best returns
Wall Street's ever seen year and you're
out even in this year where were taping
this in 2020 and that's April and I'm
giving you a scoop here right now but I
haven't written it yet but you may
continue to do really well this year as
well it's crazy
and so yes social rights if you wouldn't
it's about luck but he's a worldly
person and he's had to confront the
issue of a bad luck in his life as well
yeah yeah I think the other thing that
really you know kind of speaks to me
about Jim is that he he is comfortable
being in so many different worlds
whether academia like we talked about
finance but he has he has no heirs and
he still does you know
Boston you know kind of bread thick
gravelly accent you know cutting cutting
presence when he comes into the room but
I don't know if you watch the show
billions on a John showtime view like oh
it's just too close to what I do day to
day so yeah the way from but it's yeah
very good yeah I know I never watched
The Big Bang Theory even people as
there's an ax people ask me all the time
about his character acts in the TV show
that was your fire exactly right yeah
it's luckily it's spelled differently so
I've no remote captain that done that
particular act but you know we've been
watching it my wife and I you know in co
vid care you know kind of just just the
wind down at the end of the day but but
you know it's kind of if if there is you
know reality associated it's not you
know not say for for viewing at the
office but but you know and that could
be a little bit graphic for those of
these not for children certainly but but
you know the cutthroat world depicted
couldn't be farther from the Jim Simon's
that I know
of course you know you can only know so
much about a person but he's intensely
private on one side you know and then on
the other side he has a you know multi
million view TED talk about his life
which was you know with Chris Anderson
himself you know the father of Ted I
wonder how do you reconcile those two
different aspects I mean one of us you
know most often use quotes is from
Animal Farm you know where the donkey is
asked you know you're so lucky you have
this tail to keep away the Flies and he
said well I'd rather not have the Flies
and not need the tail and you know
that's Jim's perspective you know I'd
rather not have all this attention and
then you know he'll he'll make a speech
that'll bring down the house so listen I
think Jim Simons is a remarkable
individual a good person and I'm a
cynical skeptical journalist but let's
also be clear one of his passions in
life is money he loves money he's loved
money from the day one he's wanted to be
wealth from day one he doesn't throw his
money around but he enjoys finer things
as well as got a nice home and super
yacht and all that so when it comes to
money he pursues it and he always has
he's been very focused on that from the
day one and people close to him we're
never sure why some people family
members and others and her friends
thought maybe he wanted the money he
knew he had to get really rich to have
impact on society and he's done that but
you could make criticize um's of him as
well so listen one of the sad things for
me is as we struggle here trying to deal
with this pandemic that all this brain
power is that hedge funds you're trading
markets they're trying to make a little
money here mill money there and these
guys are much smarter than I could ever
be and if we're looking for it this is
what they do they look for patterns
should shouldn't some of that brain
power be used potentially to find some
the patterns and in what we're
struggling with right now and it almost
is sad to me at the end of the day that
they've siphoned off all this talent
from your world from the world of
academia for the world of medicine
hypothetically to the world of training
which it's a net net it's taking money
from somebody at some other investor now
they would counter in one counter that
well people like Jim Simons have made so
much money they've gone on and done
the great things with that it multiplied
it and you know Bill Gates has made the
same argument and Warren Buffett and
it's a strong argument um you could also
make the argument that they've done
other things but that Robert Mercer is
his partner is the single most important
individual I would argue to the rise of
Donald Trump so these are also very
complex individuals and I like that as
an author a lot of times people with my
books especially a lot of people come
away going yeah Greg I really like the
book but I don't know if I like the
characters and that's true of the
frakkers and the greatest rate ever and
in this one as well and that's fine by
me I personally think Jim Simons is one
of the most remarkable fascinating
characters and a good person but yeah
he's not a saint either no look that's
as he said that's your job and you know
I'm I'm tempted you know again to make
you break your you're bound to watch
billions because there are characters in
there that you know one remind me of you
you know as a reporter for the journal
but they don't like the financial Street
Journal or something yeah but it's a guy
who's like going after the billionaire
hedge fund guy but he's also got the
side where he can be flipped and go for
the state prosecutor of the Southern
District prosecutor prepared by jima
anyway you should watch it but the point
I'm getting at is Jim is not like that
kind of chop shop or a boiler room you
know kind of character I'm not and I'm
not I'm not at all purely everything
because your apartment the field as a
whole I will say though because I've
asked him you know and in the in the
beginning I had some students that were
incredibly brilliant and they weren't
suited for the world of academia by
their own nature and so I said well you
know maybe maybe instead of working on
the Symons you know Telescope funded
projects by the foundation maybe you
might like an introduction or maybe they
asked me for an introduction to some of
the contacts I had a renaissance back in
the day I'm not super close with people
at Renaissance anymore obviously
Jim Simons is formally retired but he's
you know still an active member in terms
of you know the philosophy and
maintenance of the fund but he he said
to me look I'm not hot we don't hire
quant so much anymore and I was kind of
surprised but I know personally
professors who dropped out of astronomy
and went to go work for and you know to
play devil's advocate to what you just
said I mean he was you know his point
was that eventually you get this phenom
that you described in the book with you
get like over models so it becomes like
there's only so much you can do and you
see this nowadays unfortunately the
incidence of Co vid and forecasting was
gonna pee when's this resource gonna be
you know you can have a model for every
person and question is you know when you
have only scientists working he told me
that that they were actually suffering
in some so they had some internal rubric
or metric by which they were realizing
that they actually needed some of these
scientists to have some business
knowledge and they really didn't they
didn't understand the basics that an MBA
would have fresh out of school even
though obviously an MBA can't do the
same kind of very high-level
quantitative mathematical approach that
they do and so I think he's moderated
that so I think there is less of that
brain drain than you might think
although there are still people there
look they're incredibly private we don't
really know what they do but the bottom
line is you know there's there's a
balance and I think you know some people
want to do stuff in academia and then
have it applied to the quote/unquote
real world rather than you know letting
these tools only be of use to some
abstract you know abstruse calculation
about the early universe for example but
I get your point
I get like yeah that it's you know it's
interesting how he can be you know
private on one side public on on the
other side I think again
his overarching you know it's not like
he's gonna another billion dollars gonna
mean that much more to him as in a
personal wealth like you know we always
joke from that line and in Wall Street
you know it's like how many yachts can
you water-ski behind you know like I you
know told that to my friends who are
quants to and it's like how much money
can you make fine but he is devoted to
this and he wants the foundation he's
told me persons he wants the foundation
to last forever
that to me means he's going to endow it
with the vast majority of his wealth and
wealth generated by this engine of
capitalism and argue about it as you
like but but you know without which we
wouldn't have these discoveries that's
you know he's he is you know he thinks
closing in on the first you know cures
or treatments for autism as you close
the book with I found it very very
flattering that the things that he's
most interested in in life are kind of
those big questions on one
and the origin of time the origin of
life the origin of you know how matter
came to be the kind of stuff that I
study and then this kind of stuff that's
very practical for people that are
suffering with with diseases and
conditions and maladies on earth and he
you know just as a you know kind of out
there I don't know if this is insider
information but he no he invests in
companies that are looking for cures for
example for code and and so forth so I
think you know and and he has this huge
repository of genetic information that
people you know under his 'm under his
supported organizations are working on
for example in autism building up
databases for the first time applying
some of the quantitative techniques you
know that are used in the quant field to
do this so can we can I step back for
listeners who aren't familiar with you
know what does quantitative analysis
what does technical analysis is it just
looking at you know the tea leaves or
can you explain you have an explanation
what these things are well sure so I
guess when Jim Simons began trading
investing in a serious way there were
two approaches to making money there
were sort of the random walk approach
and nutrition market you can talk about
Chicago School etc where you can't
really beat the market if you see
examples like a Warren Buffet you know
that's like that a monkey writing
Shakespeare kind of thing with the
random walk the idea is you can't like
predict the future
news so he can't really connect to
predict future prices and the other of
you was that by doing research
traditional kind of talking to
approaches like talking to management
looking at fans reports that Peter Lynch
approach then you can beat the market
and Jimmy try to completely embrace the
completely different third approach
which was akin to technical analysis and
the people I spoke to work there in the
70s and 80s saw themselves as technical
analyst and just for your audience who
don't know what that is there is this
kind of ancient kind of approach where
you look at charts and you build charts
for the patterns of finance or any kind
of financial instruments and if you
scrutinize it enough
with the naked eye even you can see
potential patterns in what Jim and his
colleagues did was they said well we
think there's some some order here to
the this chaotic market and we're gonna
do it in a Jew technical analysis in a
much more sophisticated way and they
became pioneers in this approach they're
not the only ones there are people not
too far from you and so up in Southern
California a few others who embraced it
early and Jim wasn't the earliest but he
was an early pioneer and they said we're
gonna build mathematical models we're
gonna we're also going to kind of try to
trade and invest in a way that
eliminates all the behavioral economics
mistakes that we all have come to learn
and it didn't think all babe they
recognized back then but all the
mistakes the dumb stuff though the
things were apt to do greed and fear and
all the things in between and Jim said
you know we're gonna let the computers
we're gonna turn me where I want to turn
it over to a computer and part of it was
just his son being uncomfortable with
traditional trading approaches when the
way he described it to me it's others is
when I made a lot of money I felt like a
hero when I lost money I felt like a
dolt
you know that whole kind of old-school
dope you know because they dope anymore
but it's a closet I think you're I'm
dope whatever but Jim decided to take
this other approach where we're going to
turn the decisions over to the machines
and create algorithms and in so many
ways
there is one of the reasons I want to
write the book is Jim's obviously a
pioneer when it comes to this
quantitative approach but he's also a
pioneer when it comes to machine
learning and artificial intelligence
they were doing this ticking to go um
big data didn't call big data but they
brought up all this data and cleaned it
when no one was calling cleaning and you
know and care about that kind of thing
and no one cared about the day that he
was buying data when no one cared about
so it's a whole different approach that
Wall Street and broader society has
embraced you know Facebook comes on in
your world and Netflix and it's all
predictive algorithms and that's what
these guys were doing Jim Simons and his
colleagues in the 1980s and in 1990s and
some of the biggest breakthroughs as
people who read the book will see worked
those that Jim Simons authored and some
people that's another criticism
but well you see it you caught the man
who solve the markets really the man and
that's true it's not unlike Steve Jobs
who's the architect of in the genius
behind Apple but he also didn't come up
with a lot on the break there wasn't
that similar to what Jim Simon's great
great taste and you could buy speak to
that I heard a lot of professors he
worked with talk about he was a very
smart guy obviously but they were amazed
by his taste and he knew what kind of
problems I think to to to tackle and
what what problems not to tackle so in
all those ways he's very much a pioneer
that we can all learn from that's right
yeah I think I think that is sort of the
intangible you know secret secret sauce
that really separates people like him
and you know I think there are other
people you know who who might even be
more financially successful but in terms
of you know stacking up these these meta
skills from from you know the social
psychology of working with these people
to the pure technical and and you know
infinitely complex theoretical you know
understanding that he has in terms of
basic mathematics but I think again what
really what I always associate with him
is this relentless curiosity that he
just he just doesn't give up he has to
understand stuff he's not afraid to ask
questions even if it makes him you know
I mean sometimes the only he'll ask you
to explain something you know several
different times and and and you'll walk
in that he's trying to think of
everything in terms of perhaps his first
love you know geometry understanding
they knew abstract spaces and even
charts and technical you know graphs and
in quantitative analysis in terms of
curvature and and derivatives and so
forth in a geometric sense not in the
financial sense and it's almost like
yeah I mean I didn't I didn't know so
much about that before I read the book
of his his younger sort of aspirations
at you know well that I don't ever get
the sense its wealth as a as a scorecard
the way that some people do to approach
wealth and the conspicuous you know
celebrity you know predicated on you
know amassing little wealth and then
somebody else I think it was pretty
interesting you know when I was with him
we took him down over the summer last
year in 2019 the
Northern Hemisphere summer to the Symons
Observatory site to do a groundbreaking
and of the of the future site and to
visit the Simons array which is already
operating at 17,000 feet above sea level
now this is a guy who was you know spin
smoking merit cigarettes for the better
part of the last 60 years and as in his
early 80s right now and go back to the
whole theme of luck and they're all luck
today's they go on yeah right yeah so
you know I had luck to try to you know
kept you know station caches of oxygen
and you know supplies and and I'm one of
my favorite pictures getting him like
shoveling you know dirt at 17,500 feet
and he's just yeah doesn't care he just
wants to do it and then as soon as we
were down below a safe altitude you know
don't tell his doctor his doctor because
doctors you know five years older than
he is but anyway we got the approval and
him he was he was you know his healthier
than I was and he was a shoveling dirt
and marching around the site yeah yeah
he's a freedom to wear socks for the
first time remember he had never played
socks before yeah he's a freak of nature
he's a sharpest attack he's approaching
83 he goes on hikes with the Simonson's
foundation and members there younger
people and he's leading the pack okay
thank you early what he considers
himself a ponderer and he said to me he
was in grad school and you realized he
wasn't the quickest you know he's
accomplished so much in math and
geometry etc but he doesn't consider
myself to be the quickest mind but geez
he knows that those problems and even
when he was a young kid his mother some
of us had to get him out of a tree in
the tree just thinking for a long time
and he embraced these kind of menial
jobs like sweeping and floors I began my
book talking about it he liked these
menial jobs because it allowed him time
to think so he's a ponder and I'm just a
fascinating mind a beautiful mind in
someone anyways but I thank you for this
book and the opportunity to chat I'm
sure things are super hectic on Wall
Street you you hinted that they you know
that perhaps Jim is not you know making
out too poorly he won't be you know
downsizing to to a minor yacht instead
of a mega micro
but hopefully hopefully the foundation
is that remains stable and continues to
the great work they do not only in
cosmology obviously that's my personal
interest but the Flatiron Institute
which they support and the research
science foundation autism research
initiative
you know they support hundreds of
millions of dollars in science pure
scientific research not really acting
basic research base aim he's one of the
biggest went to three biggest funders of
basic research today you know you could
argue you know maybe it's a shame that
it takes billionaires today to do that
to be responsible but he's doing he
objectively doing really great things
with his mind yeah and I think you know
it's filling a niche that is done also
in public private partnerships with the
National Science Foundation yeah you
know giving giving tons of money to to
research to to understand the cosmos and
healthy human beings get a better
understanding of the cosmos is all about
so I just want to close by thanking you
also mention your other books the
frakkers rising above two books written
with your sons Gabrielle and Elijah who
I've had the pleasure to meet at your
book launch party that was really fun
thank you for inviting me if I come look
we discussed today is the man who solved
the market how Jim Simons launched the
Quandt revolution written by Greg
Zuckerman it's endorsed by Malcolm
Gladwell Michael Lewis
it was Mohamed el-erian Edward Thorpe
and I just want to what are you working
on now besides the stuff for the journal
I'm coming hands full with journal stuff
market stuff but what I'd love to do
having to share this with anyone I'd
love to write a story about whoever
comes up with the vaccine God willing
there is a vaccine for for this [ __ ] i
that that that stops this pandemic in
his tracks so I like I like science at
one point I was really thinking about
doing a book about immunotherapy and the
frackers got into some of the signs and
obviously got some math with this book
but so if I can and I haven't really
done I work with I'm overwhelmed with
work at the journal but if I could write
a book about the individuals who've
figure out the treatments in the in the
vaccine for Ovid I would
that would be a real pleasure and a
privilege but let's see if I can figure
that out yeah I think I think you're
absolutely right I mean it would make
almost like a detective story starting
Raj another the virus the Chinese
cooperation with the with the West and
and how we can overcome this and avoid
repetition as an idea 18 flu yeah it's
sort of I like just it might be
interesting might not be but I do see
you know there being some green shoots
from this awful tragic
you know consequence the consequences of
this pandemic obviously every single
life is is an infinitely tragic loss but
but that it could be that what the
Manhattan Project did for physics in the
20th century and mathematics and you
know without that there probably
wouldn't have been a Jim Simon's working
at the idea you know the Cold War that
there may be a new century of a biology
of biophysics certainly with all the
great breakthroughs that are coming with
crisper and and so forth and how we're
now seeing how we you know can cure
diseases using viruses and it's
unbelievable
that's the the breakthroughs that my
colleagues are making all around the
world so I would definitely be
interested in reading that no doubt it
would be another one all right there you
go and I'll come back you know a few
years we can do this again I'll be
awesome all right Greg thank you so much
the right-hander's all the markets and
if you're NH wants to reach out
constructive criticism I'd love to hear
people's constructive criticism and
email me LinkedIn Twitter what-have-you
yeah well put I'll put your Twitter and
your LinkedIn profiles in the show notes
and we put it up on YouTube and thank
you very much Greg alright great seeing
you will be well thank you
[Music]
short of about the future is it it will
be absolutely fantastic
[Music]